actually there's a
an important experiment that um that
drives a lot of what
people want to do with brain machine
interface and that's the work of bill
newsom who is at stanford and tony
mauvision who
runs the center for neuroscience at nyu
this is a wild experiment and i think it
might
freak a few people out if they really
think about it too deeply but
anyway here it goes there's an area
called mt
in the cortex and if i showed you a
bunch of dots
all moving up and this is what they this
is what tony and bill and some of the
other people
in that lab did way back when as they
show a bunch of dots moving up
somewhere in mt there are some neurons
that respond they fire when the neurons
move up
and then what they did is they started
varying the coherence of that motion so
they made it so only 50
of the dots moved up and the rest move
randomly and that neuron fires a little
less
and eventually it's random and that
neuron stops firing because it's just
kind of dots moving everywhere
it's awesome and there's a systematic
map so that other neurons are responding
and things moving down and other things
are responding left and other things
moving right okay
so there's a map of direction space you
okay well
that's great you could legion mt animals
lose the ability to do these
kind of coherence discrimination or
direction discrimination
but the amazing experiment the one that
just
is kind of eerie is that they lowered a
stimulating electrode
into mt found a neuron that responds to
when dots go up
but then they silence that neuron
and sure enough the animal doesn't
recognize the neurons
going up and then they move the dots
down
they stimulate the neuron that responds
to things moving up
and the animal responds because it can't
speak it responds by doing a lever press
which says the dots are moving up
so in other words the sensory the dots
are moving down
in reality on the computer screen
they're stimulating the neuron
that responds to dots moving up and the
perception of the animal
is that dots are moving up which tells
you
that your perception of external reality
absolutely has to be a neuronal
abstraction
it is not tacked to the movement of the
dots in any
absolute way your perception of the
outside world depends
entirely on the activation patterns of
neurons in the brain
and you you can hear that and say well
duh
because if i stimulate you know the
stretch reflex and you kick or something
or whatever you know the knee reflex
and you kick of course there's a neuron
that triggers that but it didn't have to
be that way
yeah because a the animal had prior
experience b you're way up in this
you know higher order cortical areas
what this means is that and i generally
try and avoid conversations about this
kind of thing but what this means is
that we
are constructing our reality with the
space time firing the zeros and ones
and it doesn't have to have anything to
do with the actual reality
and the animal or person can be
absolutely convinced
that that's what's happening are you
familiar with the work of donald hoffman
so he's uh so he makes an evolutionary
argument that's not important
of that we
our brains are completely detached from
reality
in the sense that he makes a radical
case
that we have no idea what physical
reality is
and in fact it's drastically different
than what we think it is oh my so so he
goes
that's scary so he doesn't say like
there's just because you're kind of
implying there's a
there's a gap there there might be
constructing an illusion and then maybe
using
uh communication to maybe uh create
a consistency that's sufficient for our
human collaboration whatever
or mammal club you know just maybe even
just life forms
uh constructing a consistent reality
that's maybe detached i mean that's
really cool that neurons are
constructing that
like that you can prove this is what
neuroscience
at his best vision science but he says
that like
our brain has actually just lost its
in on the on the path of evolution
to where we're normal
we're just playing games with each other
in constructing realities
that allow our survival but it's it's
completely detached from physical
reality like
we're missing a lot we're missing
like most of it if not all of it
well this was um it's it's fascinating
because i just saw the oliver sacks
documentary there's a new documentary
out about his life
and there's this one part where he's
like i've spent part of my life
trying to imagine what it would like to
be be uh to be a bat
or something to see the world through
the life
you know the sensory apparatus of a bat
and he did this with his
these patients that were locked into
these horrible syndromes that
to pull out some of the the beauty of
their experience as well
not just communicate the suffering
although the suffering too
and as i was listening to him talk about
this i started to realize
it's like well what you know like
they're these mantis shrimps that can
see
60 shades of pink or something and they
see this stuff all the time and animals
they can see uv light
every time i learn about an animal
that can sense other things in the
environment that i can't like heat
sensing
why not i don't crave that experience
the same way saks talked about craving
that experience
but it does throw another penny in the
jar for what you're saying which is that
it could be that most if not all of what
i perceive and believe
is just um a neural fabrication
and that for better for worse we all
agree on enough
of the same neural fabrications in the
same time and place that we're able to
function
not only that but we agree with the
things that are trying to eat us
uh enough to where we don't they don't
eat us meaning like
that it's not just us humans you know i
see because it's interactive it's
interactive so like
so like uh now i think it's a really
uh nice thought experiment
i think because uh donald
really frames it in a scientific like he
makes a hard
like as hard as our discussion has been
now he makes a hard scientific case that
we don't know about reality uh i
think that's a little bit
uh hardcore but i think i think it's
i think it is hardcore this is
blackboard i think it's a good thought
experiment
that kind of uh cleanses the palette of
the confidence we might have
about uh about because we are operating
in this abstraction space
and you know and uh you know the
sensory space it might be something very
different and and
it's kind of interesting to think about
if if you start to go into the realm of
neurolink or start to
talk about just everything that you've
been talking about with dream states and
psychedelics and stuff like that
which part of the which layer can we
control and play around with to maybe
look into a different slice of reality
it you know just gotta do the experiment
the key is to just do the experiment in
the most ethical way possible you just
i mean that's the beauty of experiments
this is why um
you know there's there's wonderful
theoretical neuroscience happening now
makes to make predictions and but
but that's why experimental science is
so wonderful you can go into the
laboratory and
poke around in there and be a brain
explorer and and listen to and
write to neurons and when you do that
you get answers
you don't always get the answers you
want but that's you know that's the
beauty of it
i i think when you were saying um this
thing about reality and the
donald hoffman model i was thinking
about children you know
um like when i have an older sister uh
she's very sane
um uh but when she was a kid she had an
imaginary friend
yeah and she would play with this
imaginary friend uh and it had there was
this whole
there was a consistency this friend was
like it was larry lived in a purple
house
larry was a girl it was like all this
stuff that a child a young child
wouldn't have
any issue with and then one day she
announced that larry had died right and
it wasn't dramatic or traumatic and
that was it and she just stopped and i
always wonder what that
um neuro developmental event was
that um a kept her out of a a
psychiatric ward had she got you know
kept that imaginary friend
but but it i it's also there was
something kind of sad to it
i think the way it was told to me
because i'm the younger brother i i
didn't i wasn't around for that but my
my dad told me that you know there was a
kind of a sadness because it was this
beautiful reality that had been
constructed and so we kind of won i
wonder as you're telling me this whether
or not
you know as adults we try and create as
much reality for
children as we can so that they can make
predictions and feel safe because the
ability to make predictions
is a lot of what keeps our autonomic
arousal in check i mean we go to sleep
every night and we give up total control
and that should frighten us deeply but
you know unfortunately autonomic arousal
yanks us down under and we don't
negotiate too much
so you sleep sooner or later um i don't
know
um i was a little worried we'd get into
discussions about the nature of reality
because i'm i it's interesting in the
laboratory
i'm a very much like what's the
experiment what would the you know
what's the analysis gonna look like
what mutant mouse are we gonna use what
what what
experience are going to put someone
through but i think it's wonderful that
in 2020 we can finally
have discussions about this stuff and
look kind of peak around the corner and
say well
neural link and people others who are
doing similar things
are going gonna figure it out they're
gonna the the answers will show up
and we just have to be open to
interpretation
you